Raptors long last they did wear last
night I was fully rooting for the wraps
for incredibly selfish reasons like
obviously I want to see them do well and
I'm proud of their franchise and what
they're doing now but ultimately I that
I was going to game 4 and I'm like I
don't want to sit in a solemn Air Canada
Centre where everyone's like waiting to
be swept like I want to be in an arena
that has a real thought that they can
win and Kevin Love and Kyrie Irving were
just hot garbage in that game so beyond
okay the humble killed that he was
awesome yeah I was so funny I was like I
told you they're gonna win and here we
are your winner Madison Square Gardens
representing Canada the world premiere
this is big for you this is really
exciting you know I've never been in
madison square garden before and to be
here to celebrate my first major studio
movie and just the feeling in the
atmosphere my mom's here Obama's here
well mom hasn't been to New York City
since nineteen seventy-four slightly
different apparently you take her around
and enjoy the actual city other than
last night at dinner I haven't seen her
little ones here as well yeah Maddy's
here as well is the first time seeing
the film ah yes yes she may not stay for
the premiere she's not the biggest fan
of movie theaters no no she still get
used to it though